Ce sont mes seins.
Ils sont une grande partie de ma vie,
comme vous pouvez l'imaginer.
Je suis la nana aux gros seins.
Vous pensez peut-être que la vie est facile
pour une femme si bénie dans ce domaine,
mais ils sont aussi une malédiction.
Pouvez-vous enlever le soutien-gorge, s'il vous plaît ?
Après plusieurs années
de les trimbaler,
J'ai décidé de faire une réduction mammaire.
Ensuite, je peux vous montrer si je supprime ici
et je vais réparer le tissu ici
dans les profondeurs de la paroi thoracique
afin que vous ayez
encore une belle épaisseur.
Je vais vous montrer des deux côtés,
qui est vraiment lourd à tenir pour moi,
donc je peux imaginer quel genre
de poids que vous devez supporter tout le temps.
Un kilo et demi.
Chaque.
La douleur est trop.
Mon corps ne peut plus les porter,
mais ma décision n'est toujours pas prise.
Après l'opération,
Tu vas avoir
une poitrine demi-boule très ronde,
qui après six semaines
tombera à cause de la gravité,
et puis vous aurez une belle forme naturelle.
D'accord.
Mon expérience est que
les dames se sentent beaucoup plus féminines
parce qu'ils obtiennent
retrouver une partie de sa personnalité
parce que très souvent les gens
autour d'eux sont fixés sur le gros sein.
Peut-être ne serez-vous pas
plus cet accroche-regard,
ce qui signifie peut-être
tu deviendras une sorte d'invisible,
mais peut-être que vous l'aimerez.
-Vous obtenez une sorte de--
-Invisible?
Est-ce ce que je serai
quand je ne suis plus celui
avec les plus gros seins de la pièce ?
-Pommes trop petites.
-Les pommes sont trop petites.
Certainement.
Nous les supprimons.
-Trop petit.
-Ce n'est rien.
D'accord.
Oui, c'est quelque chose comme B.
-C'est joli, mais c'est trop petit.
-Trop petit pour toi.
Je suppose que tu as maintenant
est quelque chose comme ça.
Oh mon Dieu, c'est lourd.
Le reste de moi est comme,
Je peux juste me débarrasser complètement de mon...
Comme ça.
Personne ne fera attention à moi avec ça.
Encore plus.
Je serai l'invisible d'âge moyen
Femme américaine vivant à Zurich.
Comment déprimant.
Ce n'est pas qui je veux être.
Dans ma tête, je mesure 5'9" avec une petite taille,
dos délicat et larges épaules.
Oui.
Je n'ai jamais aimé mon corps,
donc avoir le pouvoir
le réparer est passionnant.
Je pense que c'est bien.
Peux-tu allonger mes jambes ?
Jambes plus longues ? Oui bien sûr.
Regarde ça. Maintenant, je suis un mannequin.
C'est amusant et addictif,
mais aussi dérangeant.
-Je ne sais pas si tu pourrais.
-Oui.
Ouah.
J'ai l'air chaud.
Je suis féministe.
je ne veux pas être raccroché
sur des idéaux de beauté inaccessibles.
Elle pourrait avoir un rendez-vous.
Que Kristin pourrait totalement avoir un rendez-vous.
Regarde la. Elle a l'air bien.
Pardonne-moi.
Je ne pratique pas toujours ce que je prêche.
Je suis toujours à la recherche de la racine
de l'obsession du monde pour les seins.
J'essaie de comprendre pourquoi ils sont devenus
une source de douleur pour moi à bien des égards.
Il y a une connexion
des seins à l'objectivation
à la misogynie à l'agression au viol,
et même meurtre.
C'est vrai, à peu près.
C'est beaucoup de poids
à transporter.
Maintenant, vous cherchez probablement tous
à mes seins si tu ne l'étais pas avant.
Je vais vous dire, c'est bon de regarder.
Voici la vue de face.
Voici le côté gauche, mon bon côté,
mon côté Schokolade comme on dit en Suisse.
Le côté droit, mais sachez juste
qu'avoir de gros seins,
ne signifie pas automatiquement
que je suis bête ou facile,
et avoir de petits seins
ne veut pas dire qu'elle ne peut pas allaiter
ou elle est moins féminine
qu'une femme avec des seins plus gros.
Si une femme porte un chandail serré,
cela ne veut pas dire
qu'elle a besoin d'attention,
et si elle porte une jupe courte,
ça ne veut pas dire
qu'elle veut se faire appeler.
Mes seins sont tout ce que les gens semblent voir.
Comme je ne peux pas les cacher,
J'ai décidé de leur montrer.
Être un provocateur.
Jouer avec le stéréotype
de la femme aux gros seins.
-Bonjour.
Êtes-vous intéressé à me parler
pour mon documentaire sur les seins?
-A propos des seins?
-Oui.
Excusez-moi monsieur.
Puis-je te demander
que pensez-vous de mes seins?
-Grand.
-Ils sont.
-Ils sont grands.
-Rien d'autre?
Ils sont vraiment gros.
J'aimerais que ce soient des cerveaux.
-Vraiment?
-Oui.
-Tu n'as pas de cerveau, ou quoi?
- J'ai un cerveau.
Sont ils réels?
Oui, ils sont.
C'est beaucoup.
Qu'en penses-tu
sur les femmes aux gros seins?
Je pense sexy.
Sexy, sympa,
ou vraiment puissant, comme le canoë.
L'humanité est divisée en deux catégories :
masculin et féminin.
Le mâle se sent attiré
au regard de la femelle,
et l'attrait
de la femme est le sein.
Les fous...
Ces seins merveilleux.
Nous allons juste rester debout
pendant dix secondes d'affilée comme ça.
Maintenant, nous allons juste rire
et lève les épaules et...
Nous devenons tous invisibles.
Nous ne sommes plus jeunes,
et on nous dit que nous avons moins de valeur.
Salut tout le monde,
sommes-nous prêts à partir dans cinq minutes?
Oui.
C'est plus facile à manipuler
quand je suis avec mes amis
et il y a de la musique et un peu d'alcool.
Nous essayons de tenir le coup et d'être toujours vus.
Il a toujours été plus facile d'attirer l'attention
pour mes seins que mon cerveau,
et il y a du réconfort là-dedans.
je me cachais
mes insécurités derrière les gros seins.
Il n'en a pas toujours été ainsi.
J'étais assis en anglais,
et je continue de penser à toi.
Je suis sûr que maintenant tu es bronzée, belle,
et combattre les gars avec un bâton.
Quand est-ce que tout a changé ?
Quand ai-je changé ?
J'ai envie d'être le doux, confiant,
pas la fille obsédée par les seins que j'étais.
Je n'ai jamais voulu être sexy.
Être une chose.
J'aime me démarquer,
mais seulement quand j'ai décidé que je voulais.
Sexy?
Non, je ne pense pas que quiconque l'ait vue comme sexy.
Kristen était jolie, intelligente et drôle.
Innocent.
La fille d'à côté.
Elle s'habillait comme une enseignante.
Elle n'a pas bu,
ne fumait pas, n'embrassait pas les garçons.
Seins? Moyen, régulier.
Elle était proportionnée.
J'ai adoré être la gentille fille,
la fille innocente,
mais tout s'est terminé à 22 ans
quand j'ai grandi d'un pouce
et mes seins sont allés
d'un C à un triple D,
puis est devenu encore plus grand.
Je suis parti de la fille d'à côté
à une femme avec un énorme rack,
et ça a tout changé.
Comment les gens me regardent,
comment je me regarde.
J'aimerais pouvoir la retrouver.
Avant de lâcher ces melons géants,
Je rentre chez moi pour parler aux gens
qui m'a connu quand j'étais tout simplement Kristen.
Attention à bien attacher votre ceinture,
insérer l'extrémité médiane
dans la boucle pour sécuriser...
Mesdames et Messieurs,
c'est un plaisir de vous accueillir à Boston,
où l'heure locale est 15h11.
Veuillez rester assis
avec votre ceinture de sécurité attachée.
Salut maman.
C'est là que j'ai grandi.
Une petite ferme du New Hampshire.
J'ai détesté.
J'avais l'habitude de crier après les vaches
et pleurer dans la grange
tout en chantant des airs de spectacle.
j'attendais toujours
que quelqu'un vienne me secourir.
Cela dit Kristin. Peut-être 83.
Vous êtes ici, juste ici.
Je le fais sans te toucher.
Vous êtes ici.
-D'accord.
-Je suis ta mère.
Je suis plus grand qu'en 83.
Je pense que cela dit Kristin juste là.
Dans ma famille,
parler de corps était tabou.
Quand mes règles sont arrivées,
Je n'avais aucune idée de ce que c'était.
Quand mes seins sont arrivés,
Je voulais juste les cacher.
On doit garder ça si jamais tu...
Il y a une autre photo de nous,
et j'avais un gros pull,
et je me souviens que papa a dit
devant tous ces gens
quand nous avons dit au revoir pour l'été,
"Tu as l'air enceinte."
Devant eux tous.
-Être mortifié.
-Je sais.
Je sais qu'il essayait juste
être drôle probablement.
Il ne savait pas comment se comporter avec une fille
qui a peut-être aimé un garçon pour la première fois,
ou je ne sais quoi,
mais c'était mortifiant.
-Bien sûr.
-Enceinte?
-Tu avais 15 ans.
-J'avais 15 ans et je n'avais pas de soutien-gorge.
Je veux dire, je n'étais même pas un C.
-J'étais probablement un B alors.
-Probablement.
Mais quand je suis devenu plus grand
et plus gros, nous n'en avons jamais parlé.
Non, nous n'avons pas beaucoup parlé
à cause des membres de la famille.
-Droite.
-On n'en a pas beaucoup parlé.
Que pensez-vous de l'opération ?
-Avez-vous un avis là-dessus ?
-Je pense que c'est depuis longtemps.
Les médecins à qui vous avez parlé
dans le passé disait que c'était de la chirurgie esthétique.
Vous n'avez pas besoin de le faire,
mais je suis curieux de savoir comment
cela va affecter votre personnalité.
tu vas y aller
de cette voluptueuse blonde ou brune...
-Ça dépend.
-À une femme encore belle.
L'attirance que les hommes te donnent maintenant
juste parce que tu as
les gros seins disparaîtront.
Tu seras une fille normale
marcher dans la rue,
et les gars vont encore te regarder,
mais pas avec ce même vavoom.
-Nous ne savons pas ce qu'ils pensent.
-Ce qui est bien, mais ce sera différent.
C'est ce que je pense aussi.
Ce sera super parce que j'aimerais
ne pas avoir cette attention,
mais en vieillissant, tu ne fais pas tourner les têtes
autant qu'avant.
-Je le fais encore.
-Je le sais.
je dis juste moins
qu'avant, peut-être.
-Droite?
-Oui.
Il y a des gens...
Ma mère a vu une pub pour Miss American
Concours d'adolescents dans le journal.
Il y a plein de monde
qui ne tournent même pas la tête.
Oui, c'était...
Ce qui m'a convaincu de le faire
était le concours de talents.
Vous avez gagné, bien sûr.
Je voulais être interprète,
et j'espérais que ce serait
mon ticket de sortie de la vie à la ferme.
Quand j'ai gagné pour la beauté, j'ai été déçu.
Quelqu'un d'autre a gagné pour son talent.
-Grand-mère était là.
- Qu'as-tu à dire, Diplômé ?
J'ai grandi maintenant.
Je suis inspiré.
Inspiré.
Mangeons et apportons-moi un verre.
-Wow, c'est bien d'avoir ça.
-C'est, c'est super.
Personne n'est jamais venu me sauver
de ma vie à la ferme.
Quand j'avais 30 ans, je me suis finalement senti assez courageux
partir pour la grande ville
et le faire en tant qu'actrice.
J'ai quitté un monde où tout le monde me connaissait.
À New York, tout le monde a vu
était une fille blonde avec de gros seins.
J'ai appris à m'en servir.
Les rôles qu'on m'a proposés étaient le sexy,
le régal pour les yeux, la prostituée de grande classe.
Je voulais être une actrice sérieuse,
mais avec ces seins,
le monde me regardait différemment
que ce que j'ai vu dans le miroir.
J'ai quelques yeux de côté.
Certaines personnes y sont très douées.
Je pense que beaucoup d'hommes
sont devenus vraiment bons
à regarder totalement très rapidement
et regarde au loin
quand ils pouvaient se convaincre
qu'ils ne regardaient pas tes seins,
mais ils l'étaient totalement.
Il n'y a rien de mal à regarder.
C'est bouche bée, regarder,
et de faire des commentaires inappropriés.
C'est le problème.
-Je suis Kristin, qui es-tu ?
-Je suis purement Patricia.
Purement Patricia ?
-Vous êtes magnifique.
-Merci.
Je t'ai vu passer,
et je me disais, c'est un New-Yorkais.
-Ceci est incroyable.
-Je suis new-yorkais.
Es-tu? Tu es.
Je fais un film documentaire.
Je fais un film sur mes seins.
Je vais les embrasser ici.
C'est ce que fait un vrai New Yorkais.
Aucune inhibition.
Allez-y.
Je pense qu'elle devrait enlever son manteau.
Je suis également styliste à New York.
Vous êtes styliste.
Où sont vos seins les plus populaires ?
Outre le fait qu'ils sont réels.
Vous pouvez dire qu'ils sont réels.
-Tu sais comment tu sais qu'ils sont réels ?
-Comment?
Quand tu les embrasses,
ils ont un petit rebond.
J'aime ça.
Il faut que je vous dise,
ce sont mes lèvres dessus.
-Oui.
-Oh mon Dieu!
Si cela s'est produit lors de mon arrivée,
j'aurais pensé
c'était amusant et j'en suis resté là.
Un truc très new-yorkais.
-Passe une bonne aprés midi.
-Aujourd'hui, je ne sais pas trop quoi en faire.
J'ai fait une œuvre d'art performance
à ce sujet pour perturber l'esprit des gens.
J'ai fait de mes seins les objets ultimes.
Bienvenue au poids des seins.
S'il vous plait, asseyez vous.
L'artiste vous invite
sentir le poids des seins.
D'accord.
Maintenant?
-Oui.
Vous venez de toucher une paire de seins.
Qu'est-ce que cela vous a fait ressentir?
Un peu anxieux.
Gêné.
Moins érotique que je ne le pensais.
C'était comme un sac plein d'eau ou de liquide.
Je pense que c'était comme
toucher un morceau de viande.
Oui, une paire de seins
tout seul n'est pas sexuel.
Ils doivent être attachés à,
du moins pour moi, une personne.
Séparer mes seins de mon corps fait
ils ressemblent à des morceaux de chair démembrés.
Ils ne sont plus sexy.
L'opposé.
Cela m'a fait me sentir comme une chose.
Je suis un tout.
Vous ne pouvez pas seulement choisir une partie.
-Êtes-vous sérieux?
-Oui.
C'est à propos de vous faire une réduction mammaire ?
-Oui, c'est plus que ça, mais oui.
-Tu n'es pas sérieux putain.
-Je suis sérieux.
Pourquoi?
-Ce n'est pas bien ?
-Non, je veux dire, c'est comme une partie de toi.
-Pourquoi voudriez-vous changer cela?
-C'est une partie de moi, mais j'ai mal.
Earl et moi étions dans un off-Broadway
jouer ensemble il y a 15 ans.
-Laissez-moi vous regarder dans cette lumière.
-Pourquoi?
Je suis attiré par toi.
-Il ne faut pas trop s'approcher.
-Pourquoi?
-Mon père est à cette fête.
-Est-ce qu'il est du genre jaloux ?
-Non, il est du genre riche.
-Je vais devenir riche.
-Es-tu?
-Je suis déterminé à.
Alors faites-le vite.
N'y a-t-il pas autre chose
pouvez-vous faire en plus d'une réduction mammaire?
Tu sais combien de fois j'ai entendu ça ?
Ce ne sont pas tous les hommes qui disent cela.
C'est comme, obtenir un meilleur soutien-gorge.
Pourquoi ne pas perdre dix kilos ?
Faites des exercices pour le dos.
Tu manques...
-Je ne suis pas un mec aux gros seins.
-Oui.
- Je me fous de tes seins.
-Droite.
C'est quelque chose à ce sujet.
C'est une partie de vous.
-Je comprends.
-C'est comme tuer...
Je ne crois pas non plus aux implants mammaires.
-Oui.
-La réduction est presque pire, en quelque sorte.
-De quelle manière ?
-On ne m'a jamais demandé ça avant.
Je n'ai jamais pensé à cette question,
mais quelque chose à ce sujet me rend triste.
-Pourquoi riez-vous?
-C'est triste.
Ouah.
Non, votre point est tout à fait vrai
que ça va me changer physiquement.
Et si vous vous sentiez différent ?
Et si vous le regrettiez ?
Vous pouvez les faire augmenter,
mais alors ils sont faux.
-Droite.
-Vous ne pouvez pas annuler cela.
Non c'est vrai.
Et si vous vous sentiez
comme si tu avais fait une erreur.
Ce n'est pas émotif pour moi
car qu'est-ce que je m'en fous ?
Oui, tu n'arrêtes pas de dire ça,
ce qui veut dire qu'il proteste trop.
- C'est Shakespeare ?
-C'est.
-Oui merci.
-Je pense que tu le sais.
Je me soucie toujours de ce que les hommes
pense à mes seins.
C'est gênant.
J'utilise mes seins comme des objets, après tout.
J'ai commencé à voir mes seins
différemment quand j'ai eu un bébé.
Hé, madame.
Salut.
Ça dit quoi? La maternité est ma quoi?
Ma muse.
-Je l'ai porté rien que pour toi.
-Salut.
Tellement content de te voir.
Bonjour beauté.
-Je n'arrive pas à croire que tu aies eu un bébé.
-Moi non plus.
C'est tellement agréable de vous rencontrer.
Salut.
Il est comme, je suis dans la position.
Je sais ce qui se passe.
Je sais ce qui s'en vient, maman.
-Voilà.
-Nous y voilà.
Cette chose où il me tient la main.
C'est nouveau.
Oui.
Merci.
Freud apparemment
avait l'habitude de dire que pour ses patients,
disait-il, je suis le sein.
J'étais comme,
Chris a besoin de savoir à ce sujet.
Il disait, je suis le sein.
Comme s'il fournissait
toutes les choses que le sein
fournirait à ses patients.
Il était vraiment dans les trucs mère-père.
-Droite.
-Freud.
J'y pensais en marchant,
et j'étais comme, je suis le sein.
je suis le sein.
Tu as la meilleure maman.
-Je suis le sein.
-La meilleure maman.
Les seins sont faits pour nourrir les bébés,
mais d'abord, ils attirent le sexe opposé,
pour que vous puissiez réellement avoir un bébé.
La mienne a allaité ma fille.
Ils ont fait leur travail.
Je n'aurai plus de bébés.
je ne suis plus jeune,
et bientôt je n'aurai plus de gros seins.
Il y en a un de plus.
Pourquoi pensez-vous que je vous ai autour?
C'est tellement agréable d'avoir un homme
autour de la maison, comme dirait ma mère.
Maintenant, c'est sexiste,
et ça n'aide pas ma cause féministe,
mais c'est vrai.
Nous avons besoin d'hommes pour soulever
des choses lourdes quand on a mal au dos.
Si seulement je pouvais échapper à ces rôles.
Tu es plus grand et plus fort.
je me fais piéger
dans le cliché même que j'essaie de perturber.
C'est parti, les gens. Donnez-moi ma voie.
Ne touchez pas à mon van.
J'adore ça, en fait.
J'aimerais être chauffeur de taxi à New York.
Je pense que je serais très doué pour ça.
Je pourrais tout à fait faire ça comme travail
si personne ne m'a jamais blessé, molesté,
me parlait de manière inappropriée,
ou m'a assassiné.
Je suis en route pour Hollywood, l'endroit
où les clichés se fabriquent et se perpétuent.
Je n'ai pas déménagé à LA
parce que je n'ai jamais pensé
Je pourrais le faire ici.
Je n'étais pas assez.
Assez jolie, assez mince, assez bronzée,
assez blonde, assez cool.
Bienvenue à Hollywood.
-Tu es arrivé.
-Oh mon Dieu!
Merci, c'est très gentil de votre part.
Au début de la trentaine, femme...
je n'étais pas assez
et pourtant trop à la fois.
J'ai constamment essayé de minimiser
mes gros seins aux auditions et sur le plateau,
mais ils étaient là,
voler la vedette.
-Zilla.
- Connie!
Tu ferais mieux d'annuler, chérie,
parce que si jamais je vous attrape tous les deux ensemble.
L'opinion publique oscille.
Starlet ne rajeunit pas.
Ça, ma chérie, c'est malheureusement la vérité.
Elle est là.
Ma fille, Jane.
Une fois j'ai vu les notes d'un réalisateur
à mon audition après qu'il ait quitté la salle.
A côté de mon nom,
il n'avait écrit que "seins".
Mon corps était un piège,
mais ça aurait pu être une opportunité.
Je me demande combien de ces femmes
dû se plier aux désirs des hommes
promettant d'en faire une star ?
Vous pouvez être une star, les gars.
Mettez votre nom sur le Walk of Fame.
Soyez une star hollywoodienne.
Je ne suis jamais entré dans une chambre d'hôtel
avec un producteur puissant
pour obtenir ma grande pause.
Je souhaite que personne n'ait à le faire.
Merci d'avoir appelé Wabi-Sabi.
Kim parlant, comment puis-je vous aider?
D'accord.
D'accord, et le nom sur votre réservation?
Vous êtes les bienvenus.
À bientôt. Bye Bye.
OK, je suis désolé, je dois juste dire ceci.
Quand je suis entré dans le restaurant,
J'ai remarqué ton beau sourire,
mais ensuite j'ai remarqué tes seins.
Je fais un film sur les seins,
et je suis généralement celui
avec les plus gros seins de la pièce,
mais les vôtres sont plus grands,
donc j'ai juste besoin de dire,
Oh mon Dieu!
Merci, si je peux demander,
Je suis un 36 HH,
et je me demandais quelle taille fais-tu?
Je fais un 36 G ou H.
-G le plus souvent, parfois un H.
-D'accord.
En Suisse, en Europe,
c'est comme un 85, ou quelque chose comme ça.
C'est juste que je suis passé du triple G,
ce qui était super,
et puis je suis même allé à F, ce qui était bien.
Puis je suis allé en G, puis je suis allé en H,
et puis je suis allé à HH, et je me dis,
HH est un peu lourd.
H est très lourd, vous savez.
-Très lourd.
-Très lourd, donc j'étais comme, d'accord.
C'est tellement drôle parce que nous avons été ensemble
tellement de ma vie
que je sais que ma mère est comme,
vous devriez faire ceci.
Ma grand-mère a dit,
vous deviendrez trop vieux si vous ne le faites pas maintenant.
Je suis comme, ce sont mes amis.
-Oui.
-Ils sont comme mes amis.
Le meilleur moment de votre journée c'est quoi ?
-Prendre mon soutien-gorge.
-Oui, c'est vrai, mon Dieu !
je ne peux pas être chez moi
pendant plus de cinq minutes
sans m'arracher mon soutien-gorge.
Les femmes aux seins plus petits
Je n'ai jamais eu de troisième sein.
C'est comme le troisième sein,
en plein dans le mille.
-Je sais.
-Où c'est comme...
Je serai sans vêtements dans la maison
toute la journée jusqu'à ce qu'il soit temps de partir.
La dernière chose que
Je ne fais qu'enfiler mon soutien-gorge et mes vêtements.
Je me coiffe, me maquille et tout.
Je prends mes douches, je mange.
Tout, et je porte ma robe
jusqu'à ce que j'aie fini avec tout le reste,
et puis je mets ce torturant,
engin merveilleusement favorable
sur mon corps
et sortir et repousser mes épaules.
Partez dans le monde
et préparez-vous pour les câlins,
les tâtonnements, les photos et les...
Vous sentez-vous comme un objet ?
Pensez-vous que les gens ne vous prennent pas
sérieusement à cause de vos seins ?
Absolument, tout le temps.
Emplois.
Groupes de personnes.
Quand je rencontre des gens dans des contextes sociaux,
ils vont juste me traiter
comme une fille avec de faux seins
venir qui met
ses seins dans le visage de tout le monde.
Je ne suis pas du tout comme ça.
Je suis si doux et gentil.
C'est l'hérédité.
Je ne les ai pas achetés.
Je viens de les recevoir.
Je les garde et le soulève, comme mon sourire.
Je fais ce que je peux.
Quand j'étais plus jeune,
parce que j'étais un bonnet C
quand j'étais en quatrième année,
J'ai eu des traumatismes,
expériences terribles.
Comme les concierges de mon école
dirait des choses très inappropriées.
J'avais ce seul emploi qui était un emploi à temps partiel.
J'avais la vingtaine et je travaillais
dans un entrepôt, aidant à expédier des choses.
Un des gérants est venu me voir
et m'a dit que j'étais une distraction.
J'étais comme, comment suis-je une distraction
quand j'arrive et que je travaille dur?
Je porte des T-shirts et des jeans,
et je travaille tous les jours.
S'ils ne font pas leur travail,
tu ne peux pas venir dire que je suis une distraction.
Tu leur dis d'arrêter de flirter avec moi
et retourner au travail.
J'ai eu ces problèmes où les emplois
regarde-moi comme un passif ou un procès.
Comme si je serais juste un procès
parce que je ne suis qu'une bimbo
ça rentre
et essayer de causer des problèmes.
Je suis toujours en colère en pensant
à propos de toutes les fois où j'ai été peloté,
appelé, harcelé,
et pire.
Vous savez, les seins sont vraiment
la seule chose que les gens ressentent...
Ils se sentent une sorte de propriété
parce qu'ils sont tellement dans le domaine public
et ils sont tellement glorifiés
et a objectivé que,
pour certaines raisons,
les gens pensent que si tu as de gros seins,
tu veux les montrer au monde
et que les gens les commentent,
et tu es une bimbo et une idiote.
C'est arrivé plusieurs fois.
En fait, Zurich
n'est pas un endroit où les hommes crient,
mais c'est définitivement un endroit où,
au cours des dernières années,
les hommes ont fait des commentaires comme ça.
Un gars dans le Niederdorf a commencé à marcher
à côté de moi et me regarde.
Puis je me suis arrêté et j'ai dit, quoi?
Il a dit que c'était incroyable.
Sont ils réels?
Encore une fois, cela semble violer.
On a l'impression d'être agressé.
Cela ressemble à une agression verbale.
Cela semble extrême,
mais c'est ce que l'on ressent.
C'est juste une histoire.
J'en ai plus.
Plus gros, plus laid.
Chaque femme le fait.
Nos corps sont en quelque sorte honteux.
On nous dit de les cacher jusqu'à ce que nous ne le soyons plus.
Lorsque nous leur montrons, le monde nous possède.
Un peu d'anxiété d'ascenseur.
C'est la bonne.
Je rencontre ma bonne amie Jeanne
et sa mère, Iris.
Jeanne et moi nous sommes rencontrés avant que mes seins ne deviennent énormes,
et quand ils sont arrivés,
et j'essayais désespérément de les cacher,
c'est elle qui m'a dit
c'est bien d'avoir des seins.
Après la naissance de Jeanne, j'étais en taille D,
et je suis passé à une taille C.
J'étais très vexé
parce que je sentais que j'avais,
tout d'un coup, quelque chose qui était bien.
Maintenant, je ne suis pas aussi bon.
Tu ne pensais pas que tu étais aussi bon
Parce que tes seins sont devenus plus petits ?
Mes seins sont plus petits,
et je suppose
cela faisait certainement partie de mon identité.
J'étais un D.
Quand j'avais 13 ans,
Je pouvais déjà sentir, comme ma mère,
comme si j'avais attiré l'attention des hommes
qui étaient bien trop vieux que moi.
J'ai attiré l'attention d'hommes plus âgés
parce que j'avais des seins de taille C.
J'avais les seins d'une femme adulte,
donc c'était déjà comme si je ne...
Je ne voulais pas cette attention des seins.
Dans notre famille, ma mère,
ses sœurs, et moi, c'était des seins.
En huitième année, j'étais une taille C.
Nous étions tous des seins,
et ils étaient certainement
voulu.
Papa t'a photographié
nue avec vos seins.
-Il aimait votre--
-Les hommes aiment photographier les femmes nues.
Ils font.
Il n'y a aucune offense à cela.
C'est de l'art.
-Bien sûr.
-Tu sais de qui je parle ?
Ce qui me dérange vraiment
à propos de tout c'est...
Surtout les femmes
qui doivent cacher leur corps.
Dans la burqa.
Cela me dérange beaucoup parce que...
Nous n'allons pas reconnaître
votre "être humain"
parce que tu es une femme,
et vous pouvez nous allumer,
et c'est ton problème.
Les femmes étaient-elles avant les hommes ?
-Vous devez porter des manches longues.
-Choses à regarder et à posséder.
Vous portez une jupe.
Vous devez être couvert.
Je suis si fatigué
de m'accrocher désespérément à ma jeunesse.
je me sens dépressif
quand je regarde dans le miroir.
Pourquoi ne devrais-je pas me sentir sexy, puissant,
et confiant à mon âge
et ne vous souciez pas de la taille de mes seins?
Sam était mon petit ami quand j'avais 18 ans.
Avant les seins.
Je voulais te voir pour plusieurs raisons.
Ça fait très longtemps.
Oui, j'ai été assez surpris
pour recevoir cet appel.
Voici la chose.
Je fais ce film sur mes seins.
Je vais subir une réduction mammaire.
-Je suis.
-D'accord.
- En avez-vous parlé à votre fille ?
-Oui, elle sait.
Elle m'a demandé quelle taille j'allais prendre.
J'ai dit que je suis un extra large maintenant,
et je serai médium.
-Pourquoi tu le fais ?
-Maux de dos, douleurs au cou, maux de tête constants.
-D'accord.
-Oui.
Ce sera aussi bien de pouvoir
porter des vêtements différents
et ne pas être regardé
à comme un monstre de la nature ou autre.
Je ne suis pas inquiet pour la chirurgie,
mais je m'inquiète de ce que je vais ressentir après,
sur le plan identitaire et émotionnel.
C'est une relation amour-haine.
Ils sont une bénédiction et une malédiction,
et j'ai l'impression que ça joue un rôle énorme
de mon identité parce que je m'objective
Je pense avec eux plus le monde entier.
Je suis la nana aux gros seins.
Je me sens, vais-je devenir plus invisible?
Si je n'avais pas ces seins
et marchait dans la rue,
voulez-vous toujours me vérifier?
C'est une bonne question.
Oui, parce que vous faites partie de ma démographie.
Je suis un homme de 50 ans.
Tu es plutôt sexy
Femme d'une quarantaine d'années.
-Merci.
-Putain oui.
Je vais totalement vous vérifier et vous draguer.
Vous avez de beaux seins,
aucun doute à ce sujet,
et en tant qu'homme, je vois que,
mais je te connais aussi,
et je suis attiré par toi
peu importe les seins.
C'est bien.
Ils sont agréables à regarder.
N'importe quel homme aimerait
de t'avoir à son bras,
et les seins ne sont qu'un avantage supplémentaire.
Je vais dire à mes amis,
elle a des seins énormes.
C'est génial.
C'est plus le droit de se vanter.
C'est ce que font les gars.
C'est vrai. C'est ce que font les gars.
C'est ce que font les mecs.
Jeanne Hoffman m'a dit
que nous devrions nous marier.
-Elle a dit, pourquoi tu n'épouserais pas Sammy ?
-Je pense que ça va arriver.
- Tu crois qu'on se mariera un jour ?
-Je pense que oui.
Vraiment? Quand?
Peut-être cinq, six ans.
-Tu viendras à LA.
-D'accord.
Je fais.
Si j'étais un parieur,
je dirais qu'il y a encore
une forte attirance entre nous.
-Je dis ça comme ça.
-Je dis juste.
Oui, j'ai toujours ressenti ça.
Oui.
-Je pense que oui.
-Cool.
D'accord, cinq, six ans ?
Je marquerai mon calendrier.
Je vous enverrai une invitation d'agenda.
Que diriez-vous de cela?
Envoie-moi
une invitation de calendrier de mariage sur Google.
Voulons-nous nous marier ?
Je ne sais pas si nous voulons nous marier.
-Ce sera amusant.
-Je recule déjà.
Je sais que vous êtes.
Tu es déjà.
Vous reculez déjà
de se marier.
Très bien, donc le 20 avril 2000.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a maintenant, 17ans?
-Qu'en est-il de 2025?
-C'est trop tard ?
- C'est bien, ça fait huit ans.
-2025?
Que veux-tu être? 70?
Va te faire foutre.
Non, tu n'es pas beaucoup plus vieux que moi.
Tu es si belle depuis presque 70 ans.
-Merci.
-Je t'en prie.
C'est l'air.
-C'est les seins.
-C'est les seins et le smog.
-Oui, 2025.
-D'accord.
C'est très bien.
Tu m'as manqué. Vous êtes si mignon.
Je viens d'entendre que tu vas
avoir une réduction mammaire.
Vous avez les meilleurs seins.
Merci de ne pas les couper.
-Se faire couper les seins ?
- C'est un crime contre l'humanité.
Ces globes ne devraient jamais être réduits.
C'est ta carte de visite, chérie.
Vous n'avez pas de cancer.
Arrêtez de vous plaindre.
Ils vont beaucoup me manquer.
-J'adore tes seins.
-Pouvez-vous me les donner?
Ne vous débarrassez pas de vos seins.
Alors vous serez comme tout le monde.
C'est ma décision.
Je le fais pour moi.
J'ai travaillé dur pour arriver ici,
et il est temps.
Moins visible ?
Peut être,
mais plus puissant.
Avant de retourner à Zurich et de rencontrer
cette nouvelle Kristen aux petits seins,
J'ai encore un arrêt à faire.
La dernière fois que j'ai vu ma soeur, Keira,
elle était toujours mon petit frère.
Je lui ai demandé si ça l'avait changé
maintenant qu'elle vit pleinement en tant que femme.
Elle a dit, je ne suis ni une fille ni un garçon.
Je suis juste moi.
Nous roulons tous les deux sur le dos.
Il y a un endroit juste ici.
Mettez simplement votre pied ici.
J'aime ça Keira
n'a pas arrêté de faire ce qu'elle aimait
juste parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
ce que les filles étaient censées faire.
Asseyez-vous simplement.
Elle est toujours la même personne
qui aime la vitesse et le danger
et peut tout réparer.
C'est aussi amusant et aussi stable qu'il en a l'air.
C'est aussi simple que ça en a l'air.
Si vous tombez, vous tombez simplement sur la neige.
-D'accord, alors on s'accroche ici ?
-Oui.
-D'accord, et se pencher avec toi ?
- Il n'y a rien d'autre que j'ai besoin de savoir ?
-Non, on va juste y aller doucement.
-Nous serons bien.
-D'accord.
Maman ne serait pas contente.
Tu veux emprunter la robe de ta sœur ?
-Pourquoi?
-Je veux le porter à la fête d'Halloween.
Il y a des noms pour les garçons
qui se promènent en vêtements de filles.
Ne sois pas stupide, chérie.
Glenn a porté la robe
à la fête d'Halloween.
Vouliez-vous avoir
les cheveux longs quand tu étais petite ?
Toujours, mais je n'avais pas le droit.
-C'était une coupe de boucher.
-Je me souviens que.
-C'était une jolie petite wiffle.
-Non, j'ai détesté.
Je me suis fait paraître aussi bien que possible.
Je ne peux pas passer par cette étape
sans que tout le monde pense que je suis un hippie.
Qu'est-ce qui ne va pas?
Donc,
même juste essayer d'être vous-même,
vous passez par une étape de ridicule
parce que les gens n'acceptent pas
vous essayez de pousser vos cheveux.
Petites filles? Aucun problème.
Ils se coupent les cheveux courts ? Aucun problème.
Les petites filles peuvent s'en tirer avec n'importe quoi
ils veulent autant que l'expression de soi.
-Les petits garçons doivent rentrer dans un moule.
-Droite.
C'est tout à fait vrai.
Oui absolument.
Puis les femmes vieillissent un peu,
et ils doivent entrer dans le moule féminin.
Alors les mecs disent tous, je dois être un mec
et je dois attirer cette femelle.
Tout le petit jeu
de qui tu dois être,
et comment tu dois être,
et comment vous devez vous représenter
est un horrible gâchis psychologique.
Je suis surpris que quelqu'un réussisse.
Se libérer des attentes,
et posséder qui vous êtes est courageux.
Keira est beaucoup plus courageuse que moi,
mais je progresse.
De retour en Suisse.
en fait je n'ai aucune idée
quelle taille je ferai après demain.
Je suis excité à propos de la chirurgie
et qui je serai au-delà des seins.
Je suis obsédé par eux depuis des années.
Je les utilise pour attirer l'attention,
pour des projets artistiques,
et défier l'image des gens
des femmes et des corps.
D'accord, j'aurais besoin
pour mesurer votre tension artérielle.
D'accord.
-Ce.
-Celui-ci.
-D'accord.
-Merci beaucoup.
-Pourquoi faites-vous celui de gauche?
- C'est plus près du coeur.
Bien sûr.
Je n'ai pas appris ça à l'école d'infirmières.
Aussi confortable que possible.
-C'est l'heure.
-Il est temps de dire au revoir.
Il est temps de dire au revoir.
Je vais bien.
-On se voit dans quelques heures.
-Tu seras le même.
-Je serai pareil.
Je serai toujours bruyant,
odieux, idiot et franc.
-Avec ce fou rire.
-Avec le fou rire.
Je pensais que ce n'était qu'un geste.
Je ferme le costume de gros buste.
Cela faisait partie d'un rôle
Je ne joue plus.
Il est temps pour un moi plus réel.
Je ne suis pas mes seins.